Me vs The Peach.
Okay, I'm gonna-- I'm gonna
swing the old meat mallet.
I'm gonna sit on him
right out of the box.
Okay? So, I could be calling
for a little bit
of the old punch bagging.
Okay buddy?
-(SIGHS)
-Ready to play the bag?
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, give it to me.
What?
What is it Greg?
Being at ATN, you know,
it's kind of like,
the one thing
I didn't want to do.
Oh, okay. So, should I
have left you at Parks to sink?
I mean, it's-- It's ATN man.
It's the fucking news.
-I know.
-It's Logan's G-spot.
I can finger-bang him
all night long.
I'm a direct, direct report.
What?
Sure, just...
ATN?
It's-- it's like...
-Kind of against my principles.
-(LAUGHS) Your principles?
Greg don't be an asshole.
You don't have principles.
Dude, ATN is a very toxic
element in the culture.
Seriously, okay, name me one
principle that you have.
I don't know, like,
I'm against racism.
Bullshit! I'm against racism,
everybody's against racism.
What else?
-Like, don't lie.
-Fuck off.
-Like, if you're the news.
-That's your principle?
-Yeah, dude.
Greg, this is not fucking
Charles Dickens World, okay.
You don't go around
talking about principles.
We're all trying to do
the right thing.
Of course, we are.
But, come on, man!
Man the fuck up.